alors que depuis fin octobre tous les
restaurants et bars ont fermé et que la
colère gronde suite aux nouvelles
annonces du président emmanuel macron
qui n'envisage pas une réouverture avant
le 20 janvier 2021
c'est autour de 20 janvier que nous
pourrons alors prendre si cela est
possible
de nouvelles décisions d'ouverture il
semblerait que tout le monde ne soient
pas logés à la même enseigne au sein de
la république
sous cette grande tente blanche où on
aperçoit de la lumière se trouve le
resto de nos députés
c'est nicolas dupont aignan qui pousse
aujourd'hui un coup de gueule en
dénonçant l'installation de cette
buvette 5 étoiles sur l'esplanade de
l'assemblée nationale dans laquelle il a
lui-même déjeuner hier plat de crudités
et créèrent yaourt voilà c'est un peu la
cantoche nous sommes allés enquêter sur
place et il semblerait bien que nos
chers députés aient pris la formule
pension complète
en ces temps de confinement une buvette
certes installé dans le respect des
règles sanitaires
mais une buvette qui provoque tout de
même l'incompréhension de la population
sont sénégal à ce que ces gens là le
droit de manger et que d'autres
personnes doivent aller dans les
boulangeries emporter se faire chier à
manger dehors des citoyens qui ne
comprennent pas pour la plupart que nos
députés ne montre pas l'exemple
normalement mais loi 101 s'applique à
tous les genres député de l'essonne
nicolas dupont aignan interpelle le
gouvernement sur l'incohérence de ces
mesures et le met en garde
pourquoi les français n'auraient pas le
droit à ce qu'on a fait pour les députés
car ce qui est en cause aujourd'hui
c'est que les deux tiers des restaurants
français vont mourir alors trouvez vous
scandaleux que la buvette de l'assemblée
soit ouverte
bravo aux équipes d'avoir fait sujet
d'avoir eu nicolas dupont aignan 1
devant l'assemblée on est sur le terrain
on est sur le coup alors la plupart
disent oui il y en a qu ailleurs quand
même pas mal de noms gilad si vous en
pensez vont être prises on est de fous
plus on rigole non sens où cela ils
doivent en parler ils doivent rigoler
ils vont pas manger avec en faisant avec
un image je pense pas ce qu'ils mangent
bien ouais moi je paie à la semaine
il rêvait c'est très beau c'est très
accueillants on est servi et c'est youpi
et que la fête continue nom est pour
vous la fête
il n'y a pas de fête n'ont ils pas tête
ghislaine vous êtes dans une situation
où vous êtes dans une telle situation
actuellement déjà moi je suis maintenant
je fais du thé que ouais ouais pour
clore le tout dans le 14e
on a enlevé tout ce qu'il y avait comme
voix devant chez moi donc j'ai des
barrières jusqu'à la fin de la semaine
c'était un mois ça dure donc j'ai pas
une voiture qui passe devant j'ai rien
du tout y'a pas de signalisation n'y a
rien on est quelques commerçants comme
ça c'est le bonheur financièrement ça
fait combien de temps que là ça devient
compliqué ça devient compliqué ça a été
compliqué dès le premier jour ça fait
donc sas en fait on s'est dit ça va
peut-être se remettre on va prévoir
hélas quand on commence à toucher à ça
c'est à voir à soi pour réinjecter dans
un restaurant c'était très compliqué et
ça c'est pas ya plein de choses qui sont
pas normales et nous on doit payer et ça
c'est pas possible nous a révoltés sa
classe la buvette et le restaurant de
l'assemblée nationale soit ouvert moi je
trouve ça je trouve ça aberrant
pourquoi ils peuvent apprendre à
plateaux repas dans leurs oeufs non
c'est un truc de la maison mais je sais
pas où et comment des plateaux rebelles
très belle maison qui est un des
plateaux repas alors y'en a qui sont pas
d'accord avec vous dire tout ça
insupportable qu'on tape en permanence
sur les politiques on peut pas comparer
un établissement qui n'est pas ouvert au
public in ouvert que à 577 députés
ils mangent pas ça 177 en même temps les
cantines d'entreprise elles sont
ouvertes c'est pareil ce n'est pas
ouvert au public et il ya évidemment les
restaurateurs sont dans une extrême
difficulté ils n'ont pas assez d'être
suis entièrement d'accord avec vous mais
on ne peut pas comparer un seul
restaurant de l'assemblée nationale et
deux cent mille restaurants en france
qui accueille des millions de français
où il ya des contaminations
donc je trouve ça insupportable et
nicolas dupont aignan est lui
complètement démago parce que lui même
il y mange à la buvette de l'assemblée
nationale il l'a dit oui ce qui est très
étonnant c'est que dans le sujet ils
disent qu apparemment ils mangent et ses
eaux avec leur équipe dans le respect
des conditions sanitaires donc ça veut
dire qu'il ya un protocole qui a été
fait pour qu'ils puissent manger lille
2-3 ce protocole n'est pas mis en place
pour tous les restaurateurs
donc si ça marchait ce pourquoi pourquoi
ça marchait pas chez les autres pourquoi
ça marchait pas dans les restaurants et
puis à vertu d'exemplarité je suis
désolé c'est eux qui équipe qui donne
l'état respecté quelles que soient les
précautions qui est d'accord alors que
lee mais dans tous les cas moi de balle
j'étais contre les cantines dans les
entreprises et les cantines dans les
lycées mais maintenant que les
continents les entreprises est celle des
messieurs sont ouvertes
je vois pas pourquoi moi je suis
d'habitude je suis contre eux et là pour
le coup je vais être avec eux je vois
pourquoi ce serait les politiques qui
devraient montrer l'exemple
étant donné que c'est la cantine de leur
taf des entreprises où il ya 500
personnes y en a beaucoup et vous savez
le nombre de personnels que ça fait
travailler en même temps dans la
restauration ce truc là donc ans alors
c'est la fin on ferme tout on ouvre tout
mais pourquoi on tombera sur ces gens là
alors que c'est la cantine de leur taf
c'est très bon donc qui met donc je suis
étonné ben oui ça peut paraître étonnant
mais moi je ne suis pas dans le truc ce
qu'ils avaient mangé dans leur voiture
un plateau repas dans la maison que les
cantines sont ouvertes
l'adie et pour remettre les trucs dans
le contexte là ils ont mis une tente en
dehors de l'assemblée faut savoir qu'il
ya un vrai restaurant dans l'assemblée
et je connaissais certains restaurants
celui là et j'ai fermé celui là est
fermée où on y mange très bien
on y boit très très bien celui là il est
fermé alors on est venu ça a été pas à
toi tartine fromage crudités et sel de
guérande saumon fumé le plat du jour
confit de canard et quenelles de cendres
et buffet dessert makrouds ma nicotine à
grenade
c'est par aux amandes excitant mais
voilà ces examens lyon c'est pour dire
que là tout le monde s'offusque dupond
et dupont aignan là qui vient nous faire
son cinéma son cinoche de démago contre
le gouvernement ok si tu veux autant
contre le mur non si tu veux mais lui il
en profite aussi mais en profiter il
n'arrête pas de changer la voix la
vapeur et on savait toutes les deux
minutes
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire les
autres les cantines d'entreprises sont
vertes si vous voulez vous révolter sur
un truc d'un combat vous voulez vous
révoltées et révoltés vous alors
j'espère maintenant gamme à manger à la
cantine pour justement dernière la
dernière partie de touche pas à mon pote
on learning gueule je vais vous montrer
une image complète fofolle d'un risque
de la restauration en entreprise bien
après tout ce qu les voiles d'avant le
regarde là les îles un meilleur oui
dernière partie de touche pas à mon
poste avec guylaine qui est avec nous et
regarder à quoi ressemble la
restauration en entreprise marie ornée
d'un truc de fou on a vu sur france 3
regarde restaurant inter entreprises
continuent de servir sur le site du
maloubier un bonheur pour cette salariée
pour mes confinement n'avait plus de
restaurants donc la fait bien plus
appréciable
la réouverture s'est faite selon des
règles sanitaires strictes masque
obligatoire sens de circulation produits
sous film plastique ou encore siège en
quinconce un contre-temps qui rassure
néanmoins les usagers depuis le coc vide
au tout début je ne venais pas là j'ai
vu que c'était respecté qu'il avait mis
en place toutes les mesures donc ben je
reviens ghislaine renvoyer sa les
restaurants d'entreprise assemblée
nationale vous dites quoi vous à moi
dans le récent d'entreprise apparemment
il ya une distanciation qui est qui et
nous on n'a pas vu comment c'était dans
le restaurant de l'assemblée nationale
bon là apparemment il n'y a pas de souci
c'est comme dans les cantines on peut
pas non plus fermer les cantines que
vont faire les parents que vont faire
les enfants il ya toute une restauration
moi je pense
ouais autant autant je trouve que dans
les entreprises c'est quand même
important qu'ils puissent se restaurer
de manière autant las la buvette de
l'assemblée c'est pas ça ne mange et non
celle des hommes politiques on a eu les
mots les aime ou on déteste mais ils ont
droit de manger qui n'avait mais
personne à coeur la buvette ça se trouve
il laisse les juges ont saisi 26 on l'a
pas dit mais tu peux pas m'en veut pas
expliquer à toute la profession
que c'est beau mais c'est qu'il faut
faire attention à exact est autorisé à
genève voilà c'est un scandale qu'on
vienne les restes d'entreprise c'est un
scandale parce que là c'est à peu près
propre
moi j'étais manger il ya pas très
longtemps dans les stands d'entreprises
ont été les uns sur les autres ou qui
n'avaient pas de 10 ans entre ferrières
s'il y avait des serveurs non mais si et
si les aides si les politiques mange
dans leur voiture ou un plateau-repas le
colis disons pas toujours bien vus
arrêter dit comment tu expliques sur
blanc c'est pas possible de recevoir
dans votre restaurant des gens qui sont
en train de crever c'est un million de
chômeurs va bientôt commencer par
améliorer la réponse parce que la lysine
là c'est des conneries se sont dit c'est
un million d'emplois dans la
restauration bons plans ils vont amener
à 300 millions c'est pas à partir dans
tous les sens tu peux expliquer la
fusion lavie cambot tu me l'as comment
tu peux expliquer chauvine dans le monde
non mais c'est pas
tu peux excuser moi ils faisaient sait
même pas d'être est un exemple et à des
gens qui ont leur dis ne pouvait pas
bosser et tu autorise ailleurs même si
hélas c'est impossible à entendre et à
contacter je suis désolé a dit oui c'est
la france d'en bas
pourquoi les restaurateurs imaginez un
petit peu leur haine de voir où ils ne
peuvent pas aussi appliquer sa porte et
scalextric pourquoi il ce qui ferait pas
appliquer aussi des règles sanogo ils
sont incapables de le faire mais aussi
d'imaginer leur désarroi envoyant un
renvoi dans les mairies la chine est
connue parviennent à faire appliquer ce
protocole strict
pourquoi le restaurateur ne peuvent pas
y armée ainsi on également les faits
autrefois la parole tant que je donnais
mais qu'est ce que tu dis on est
d'accord mais moi je pense qu'il faut
laisser les politiques tranquille assez
insupportable de voir le menu qu'est ce
qu'on s'en fout de ce qu'ils ont mangé
ils ont le droit de manger et isabelle
parler de l'exemplarité tout à l'heure à
ce moment-là macron pourquoi mâcon
voyages à l'étranger et pas nous parce
qu'il est président ça fait ses débuts
elle répondait lui ont fait sympa qu'on
mélange pas tout tous louis parce que
l'avion macroéconomie niçois après soir
voilà ce que vous devez faire
or il ne le respecte pas pour eux-mêmes
pardon massa le même habit à l'avancé ce
qui m'importe je me comprendre pourquoi
tu dis ça
pourquoi ils ne respectent pas c'est une
cantine d'entreprise les cantines
d'entreprises sont ouvertes
donc pourquoi il ne restera pas ils
n'ont jamais fermé mais je te demande
faite moi ma saison pharmacien est
fermée ne se rend pas mais je ne sais
pas c'est le fait que où on est tous
pareils suis d'abord là j'ai appelé à
l'arrêt montiel qui appeler
mais vite alors j'ai appelé l'assemblée
alors figure c'est désormais durant la
crise du coc vide s'est ouvert de 8h à
22h
sachant par exemple que samedi dernier
ils ont fini à 6 heures du matin je ne
les plains pas c'est leur job mais ils
ont des comptes à rendre à leurs
administrés tout va bien le menu caunes
a présenté par exemple tout à l'heure
ils paient en général 20 euros c'est qui
est vraiment intéressant
bon ça vaut le coup c'est on aura bien
se sont largement fait pas maintenant
pas de grenoble aurait pas d'impôt des
restos des français il ya une table par
personne et au maximum ils sont deux ils
sont séparés comme nous par des
plexiglas donc à toutes les mesures tous
les protocoles sanitaires et respectez
moi je ne compte pas arrêter de dire
n'importe quel film kodak pas entendu
là-dessus
le problème c'est qu'en france il ya
souvent deux poids deux mesures et il ya
plein de restaurateurs qui veulent aussi
mal oui lexie et on ne les laissent pas
ouvrir et on est d'accord
ils ont touché les politiques c'est les
gens d'en haut malgré tout c'est ça
c'est pas une question d usines
continuent d'en souffrir et les
politiques ils ont il ya deux poids deux
mesures les politiques peuvent et les
autres ne peuvent pas finale et on va
terminer place que on a commis les mois
du jour j ai dû arriver on sait aussi on
a les preuves scientifiques que c'est
dans les restaurants que le virus y
règne donc pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
suppriment ferait il circule moins chez
les uns que chez les autres
il faut entendre les gens ne peuvent pas
comprendre ça on est bien que oui on est
assez ghislaine à qui on va laisser le
mot de la fin
il n aura bien oui qu'est ce que vous
pouvez dire au gouvernement l'a pour les
restaurateurs est ce que ça va être le
est ce que vous allez descendre dans la
rue comme ce que j'entends est ce que
vous allez ouvrir sans autorisation
qu'est ce qui va se passer je ne je
n'ouvrirai mais pas sans autorisation
parce que je suis bête et discipliné on
sait bien que j'ai pas l'intention de
polémiquer de cette manière là mais de
toute façon je pense que de ça se finira
pas bien vraiment pas bien donc il ya
les chances du 20 janvier et à
l'échéance du 20 janvier à laquelle je
ne crois pas du tout je pense que ça va
nous reculer de 15 ans 15 alors au lieu
de vous une pierre je les chances du 20
janvier j'ai pu croire ouais moi j'y
crois pas si je peux vous donner
l'espoir j'y crois
c'est pas une piste mais c'est fait mais
on a toujours vu à bien vous serez
rouvert annoncé en janvier
et puis ont rejoint ce que le 20 janvier
ce sera bon ghislaine à moins qu'ils
aient une vie mais c'est à ça sera fait
que les noix les noix nouvel an six
accords recommence à repartir se mettre
ça et puis j'avais la raison est là où
dylan a raison même quand ça va rouvrir
le 20 janvier il faut pas penser que les
gens vont tous se jeter au restaurant on
a rouvert au mois de juin les
restaurants est ce qu'on a un petit peu
travaillé au mois de juin et après ça a
été une catastrophe ont récupéré par le
chiffre c'est vraiment une catastrophe
ouais c'est souvient d'avoir été avec
nous